gently try to concentrate or to stress
these elements in difficult period of
Polish Ukrainian relations that could
testify to possibility of such a union
or of such a geopolitical combination
with few suits keypad Laura agreement in
the first place so we have a lot of
publications in the past 15 years that
analyzed this historical agreement and
the role Ukrainians played in the war of
Poland against Bolsheviks in 1920 and
there we have such interesting books as
PDF Karpis book historian from total
about Eastern allies of Toland in this
war reminding polish readers that this
was not exclusively polish russian or
polished soviet war but this was war in
which poland had allies not only from
ukraine by the way but also from to some
extent builder russia and to some extent
from white Russia as well but Ukraine
was the most important there is also a
very important book probably the most
important polish book about that Laura
written by a historian from Krakow yummy
as a brewski that lofts at centrum heist
over Ukraine ski Republic elude ave i
guess that this is maybe even the best
book on tottori return in any language
even in comparison with very good
ukrainian books by whitman in the first
place for brewski very important
question is to to ascertain how
relations between the Torah
and his political circle and Pilsudski
looked like and he is he's absolutely
clear in his position that this
relations were not equal that agreement
of april nineteen twenty was an actual
actual polish dictate that was dictated
to ukrainian weaker partner and he
criticises I mean bruschi criticizes
Pilsudski for being still too
anachronistic in his paternalistic ideas
or stand towards Ukrainian partner
nevertheless he sees in pilsudski the
only political power that at least tried
to to to formulate a program in which
poland and ukraine or at least the part
of ukraine could create a more
stabilized
relations as two independent states
there are however many new books and
articles that are much more apologetic
in in respect of English the inspector
to a few suits key stand in nineteen
twenty towards Ukrainians such
historians as for example from from the
state an eminent polish historian Marion
kami given offski still believe that
uses key was hundred percent true
Federalists that that truly wanted to
help Ukraine due to his noble
intellectual formation that was not
anachronistic but to the opposite was
ahead of time and so on this is
relatively popular especially
propagandistic if I could say so a
position in contemporary Poland and
going back to historiography we can
mention that in discussion
on the meaning of this 19-20 agreement
there were also more detailed questions
that are very interesting concerning the
end of of this year the collapse of the
plans uses keys plants to to form or two